serving money how to set priorities your
mindset for Revenue so this is a big
reason why rope built the serve because
a lot of people have a hard time making
money off of their purpose and you have
a hard time asking and a hard time
monetizing as a result you end up doing
the thing in the evenings and weekends
and then having to have some other job
that you don't like just to pay the
bills Sam and I have talked a bunch
about making money on our on our live
streams because Zane has a hard time
asking for money it's like no Zane you
gotta charge this is how much it is we
got to charge it doesn't mean that you
still can't give things away for free at
every event that I go to when I'm
speaking there's always usually five to
ten percent of people that will give
tickets away for free some people are
homeless and you never know it you know
you never know it by looking at them
that they're homeless so you can still
have that as an element as a part of it
but you have to make money because if
you're not making money then you don't
build your business you don't build your
purpose you don't impact more people
like look at the reach that I'm able to
have because of the team if this was me
Evan Carmichael part-time doing things I
probably wouldn't even have written this
book we wouldn't be here talking and so
as I I say in the book you know money
has to be in your top five just not
number one
so you have to learn how to make money
off your business you have to because
because otherwise you're stuck with a
job that you hate uh
it just can't be number one it can't be
above everything else so when people
come in we had a guy in our live stream
two days ago I think came in and said
hey I've got a I've got two business
ideas the first one I really you know I
enjoy and I struggle with this and I
want to help other people through it and
then the other one this is hot
opportunity with my cousin like no the
first one
like don't do like hot opportunity with
your cousin that's just not the one but
that's that's how most people start a
business that's that's what most people
they just think they're gonna make a
quick Buck
um as opposed to actually being deeply
connected to it and that's when you end
up losing so it's got to be money's got
to be in your top five just not number
one
does that help probably go deeper since
since you're here that was your topic
does that help you with where you're at
yeah so some sometimes it's kind of a
you know until what is what do you do
what do you do free what you how do you
charge how much do they charge you know
sometimes uh
um I don't know I I help a lot of people
and and I feel that pressure you know
like today finally uh I get all every
day you know I you know I have this
problem and all this help me with this
I'm being helping for for years you know
but also it just even you have two
people that that many times they they
help me they bring their the issues and
and today with the first time they'll
say if you wanna
you wanna uh me to answer you just do it
through the YouTube you know so so at
least at least I I don't I used to I
used to do for WhatsApp you know I used
to do it on on the email yeah and now I
say no YouTube and if you don't do it in
YouTube I you know it's just I I feel
like it's hard because the kind of
problem you know one person one woman
was abused and you know she need to
negotiate she need to do another person
solve their business and this and so
people that that financially they're not
stable so I don't know but uh yeah so so
let's get super tactical here one in
your bio of all your social accounts we
need to have something that talks about
what they can buy
so it could be hire me for coaching it
could be check out my new book it could
be like whatever you whatever you have
for sale this is what I told Zane to do
because Zan will just give everything
away spend all his time for free and and
just love on everybody it's like Zayn
you need to make money you got to do
this so when he started doing uh his
build to serve Readers Club that um that
we launched
as he gets better at going through the
book and coaching
the idea is to train him to be a built
to serve coach and help people who go
deeper because I'm not I'm not coaching
I'm not doing coaching consultant
services I don't I don't want to do it
but Zane does so that's got to be in
your bio you got to let people know that
it's available and in the Facebook post
we talk about here's this free group
that we're launching that you can be a
part of and if you want to go deeper
with me here's I also do coaching and
here's the link
so you have you have it as part of your
default messaging so think about your
social media accounts think about your
email wherever you could potentially
talk about yourself I want you to put in
I need people to know that you have
something to sell like this is this is
the advice of people who struggle some
people are just over selling selling
everything as a sales pitch right that's
that's what you probably want to avoid
becoming and you're afraid that you
might be judged like that so
uh step number one in your social bio I
need to know like whatever what's the
what are you selling Pablo are you
selling coaching you're selling a
training what are you selling yeah yeah
coaching programs that are different
different time of year like in March
with the next problem yeah so so
something in your bio that says DM me
for coaching
you see right DM me for leadership coach
you know DME for whatever specific
coaching
um yeah just so that it's because you're
not gonna you're not gonna offer it by
default so I want to see it in the bios
so people know that you're doing it
um the next thing is if it's
uh free then make them go through some
hoops
you're spending your time on it make
make them have to do something so
telling them to ask you on YouTube is a
is is a hoop
um some people on mine
uh will be hey join us live on Instagram
join us live on sorry join us live on
YouTube
for the live stream that I do with with
Zan and Jew so somebody asked me a
question on Instagram uh and it's going
to be a long one I just respond to say
hey let's get into it on on my YouTube
live we're going live tonight at six
o'clock join us
and if they're not willing to do that
like they have to they have to show up
right they've got to own their step a
little bit
um we've had a guy who comes who's come
like eight times or something to our
live stream named Mike who keeps asking
the same questions over and over and
over again like Mike like he's always
asking purpose really the questions so
Mike did you get built to serve yet like
you have to get we're going to help you
Zan's gonna do a free one-on-one session
with you Zan offered but you have to you
have to get a copy built to serve
buy it on Amazon get the free version
like sign up for an audio audible trial
and get the free audio book anything
like you have to all your questions are
on purpose the answers are in built to
serve you have to go pick it up
and you know Zayn doesn't get anything
from it right if if we got a sale from
Amazon woohoo right anything Zayn's not
making anything but but we're making him
jump through
a hoop like you have to you have to show
if you're gonna show up for them they
have to at least do something to meet
you not even halfway but like take a
step show me that you're committed
show me that you're willing to do
something
yeah right so I like that of pushing
them to YouTube or pushing them
somewhere else so it shows you who's
willing to step up and be a little bit
more committed and I'm
I'm happy to if people want to show up
I'm happy to do it most people don't
show up and that's the problem so we had
a guy who wanted to interview me for his
podcast I get
there's tons of interview requests for
podcasts so I said come and join us on
the I uh the Youtube live and let's talk
about it so he came to YouTube live and
and I said
um I appreciate you showing up I'm super
busy right now but talk to him in the
new year and this was in maybe October
or something
uh maybe xan remembers is October
November uh and then he came back in
January he said hey I'm just reminding
you hey we said January I said you know
what yeah let's do it and and I was I
don't know if I was his first guest or
his like fourth guest he's like right at
the beginning brand new
um and because he was willing to jump
through the Hoops he got
he got access right and so that's
something that at the beginning if you
only get four comments a day it's easy
to respond to everybody but as you grow
that's going to be a real Demand on your
time and so
one letting people know that you have a
paid version and then two for free yes
we still do some but you have to jump
through a few Hoops to make it happen
um and then the third thing I'd offer
out is uh having it public
so I'll help you on my Instagram live
come on on my Instagram live and we'll
work I'll we'll work through it
um and if they're not willing to you
know option one they're not willing to
pay you option two they're not willing
to
go to another platform
and and ask you a question on YouTube or
three they're not willing to go live
with you on Instagram it's like you
gotta you gotta you gotta show up
somewhere like I'm trying here right you
gotta you gotta pull like take that at
least one step in to show me that you're
a little bit committed so that it's it's
a use of your time right a good use of
your time
um so those those three things and that
that will weed out a lot of people but
also bring you the people who are
actually ready for Change and for action
so that you don't feel like you're
wasting your time
yeah yeah welcome Louise welcome aboard
uh what else what do you guys got this
is a it's a it's a small group today so
we can make it intimate yeah I did it I
did it I'm doing the coaching the the
coaching one-on-one you know for for the
free for the free version you know and
that is that is very good you know just
I I feel on my on my group but many many
other people that comment
so but definitely definitely I need to
put a very very clear many people know
you know but uh but they just uh because
I I've been trying to build like
Community build a community on Tuesdays
where we meet you know there is like a
150 200 people you mean for Zoom you
know and and and I I teach them I work I
work on this and after that I stay one
hour with everyone you know but um but
uh some sometimes I just
they just get in no no tired but
um there is a lot of stalkers you know
there's a there's a lady that uh they
would they would appear for everywhere
and you know and and appeared on on my
WhatsApp appearing on this for
everywhere and and she will she will
follow me and my team you know this a
lot you know a lot of weird people you
know
so so so so you know and I'm more
exposed you know like so so I said oh my
God you know like now we need to deal
with it with that and and my my bigger
fear I don't know how you you feel but
my biggest fear is I say no stop it you
know stop it that's enough you know is
if she's going to go and put this
comment bad comment on on on the
Facebook there was another there was a
guy in another country that also was
talking to me last year you know I said
stay man stop it just stop it you know
I'm not going to answer I'm not going to
do that you know that's that's your
issue you know that's this you know and
and he want to make a a nasty comment
you know and so so that's that's my fear
that
I don't know it makes sense or no no
most of the time honestly it's just
ignoring
like most of them are just attention
Seekers
it doesn't happen that often but when it
does the the telling somebody to stop it
usually doesn't work usually just gets
them even more upset it's just ignoring
until they it's like the the little kid
who's yelling and raging and freaking
out and if you just ignore them they
they calm down or go you know go the
bully go pick on somebody else but if
you
um
yeah I just found like trying to or or
you have to go deep and Coach them like
or you have to like just telling
somebody to stop it is gonna be
you're likely to get them in defensive
mode yeah so you have to either coach be
willing to coach them through it or just
ignore them yeah because otherwise
you're making it worse
yeah yeah I did
but that that's that's like any coaching
if you're gonna dive into somebody's
problem
yeah um
at the beginning you make it worse
and they get defensive like a great
coach if you're not bumping up against
defensiveness you're not doing your job
as a coach you're right you have to be
when you when they start being defensive
that means you actually hit on something
as you're just saying yes yes yes yes
yes they're probably not going to follow
through and do anything
it's when they get defensive like ooh
okay that's let's talk about this
because this is your block right here
but to dive into that you have to be
able to pull them out on the other side
you can't just leave them hanging
in in the negativity
so if you don't either one want to put
in the effort to do it or two don't
think you can then it's better not to
address it at all because you're just
going to make it worse
yeah especially when they don't pay you
sure but
if you're doing even in the free
sessions I'd say
um
like you do an Instagram live coaching
yeah yeah okay you said you know you you
become yourself extra homework Pablo now
I want you in your Instagram live
sessions to say so normally I do this as
a paid service I'm a I get paid to coach
people on how to
like what do you what what's the
coaching you do leadership
uh negotiation you know how to approach
deals yeah yeah so so normally I do this
kind of work
I get paid to train people and how to
negotiate I work with sales people and
CEOs and entrepreneurs to help them
close more effective deals and that's
that's my business I get paid to do this
but every week on Tuesday I like going
live as a free service for everybody to
be able to learn from and today
we've got whoever
on and I'm going to help him right so
that people know you're still doing the
free thing but that people know that you
do this as a service as well it's not a
hard pitch it's not saying and remember
go hire me
right but you're sending contacts as
you're the expert you get paid for this
in the beginning in the beginning of the
session
yeah in the beginning of the session and
you can storytell in the middle if it
makes sense
right so you know for example one of my
clients when I was just working with a
client on this yesterday
and his biggest problem was he didn't
know how to X right the fact that you're
saying one of my clients obviously not
gonna say the name and what company
they're from and you can change the I'll
change gender a lot I'll say guy when
it's a girl and the opposite because it
doesn't matter who the person is it's
just the story right
um so that people know if you're telling
stories about how you're coaching people
it's not it's not what the just intent
to try to sell people you're you're
telling that story for a reason
but it positions you as a coach and that
oh he does this as a service ah maybe
maybe he can help me negotiate my next
deal
mm-hmm yeah
perfect yeah
I have a question yeah
go ahead so
um I saw you and Cam's uh IG live and
you suggested that he you know do a
30-day challenge well I had already had
this workbook that I had created like
last October November so I decided to
launch it and I did I got two people
that signed up
but I closed the registration on the
25th because I wanted to just like you
know focus and make sure I was walking
them through the workbook and I got the
Facebook group and all that other stuff
but it it prompted me because I've been
really wanting to do like a six-month
program where I walk people through how
I you know changed my mindset and got to
the space that I'm in today
um and I'm really not sure how I want to
do it I don't know if I want to do it
just in 30 day increments you know like
the first month we do mental the second
month we do emotional the third month we
do spiritual or if I just want to offer
it as like a six month program
um I still want to keep the same format
where people come into the Facebook
group and it's a private Facebook group
and I'm there you know offering support
I'm there going over the the questions
every week I'm just needing more
I guess more Direction on how to
effectively Market that or your your
Genius expertise on how I should really
launch that
I just drank down the wrong way
perfect timing um I think six months is
too long
okay
um I think somebody might sign up for it
but I think what I would do is
have your different modules break it up
into six different things
okay and then I need to be able to join
in the next module
so as long as they're not building on
each other right like
module one if it's mindset what's module
one module one is mental mental mental
so what I'm doing is six pillars of
um got it what's what's the name of
number two
number two is emotional perfect so I I
need to be able to join at emotional
okay I missed
the mindset or the mental okay they're
connected it's part of this whole thing
but right but they don't have to go they
don't have to flow like that they don't
have to flow I don't feel like if I join
in on the second one I missed out on the
first one
the self-contained modules with
challenges if you want like here's what
we're going to do in the next 30 days
somebody might sign up for all
all six months of them all six pillars
at once right awesome but you can have
that as an option most people won't most
people will just sign up for hey we're
starting our
30-day emotional challenge
to help you get your emotions right for
your business or however you want to
position it and
and they could still sign up for the
whole year or for the whole six months
right they just get mental at the end
gotcha right so I should just keep it
rolling
every every so after the six months is
up we start the next seventh month on
mental yep okay and you've learned
something now because you've now gone
through it with people your mental at
seven will be better than mental at one
right and then what I would do is give
some kind of alumni discount say hey you
want to go through this whole thing
again
okay you get it again at like a quarter
of the price or something okay so yeah I
was thinking about doing the six
um different modules and then just group
you know I still want to keep it like at
the same price point you know it's just
the workbook but you get the free
Facebook group Community me there you
know doing lives at the end of the week
and every single day or every week
coming on to go over the challenges or
whatever I have for that week but
um
and then offer so what I just create one
book for the people who want the six
months all together or do I still keep
them separately separate okay and you
give them all six books okay or six PDFs
or whatever yep six PDF Zan and I were
talking about this too with the built to
serve readers group it's like it's got
to be long enough that people can learn
and interact and have fun and and you
know make connections but if the group
starts up every six months it's just it
just takes way too long to get the next
cohort going right so built to serve
does does build like it's hard to jump
in at chapter eight and Zayn's talking
about who I how and they're like what
does that mean you know so
the book goes into sequence but but for
you yeah if you're looking at a
six-month program that's your best bet
you sell the 30 days you sell the six
months and then you sell once they've
gone through it to come back and do it
all over again just as as a refresher at
a
discounted rate
so just one more thing so
um really what I was thinking about
doing is like April to October then
taking November off and then starting
back in December would no you just want
me to just go right into November okay
because it's just gonna be some people
sign up on month four but but for them
like I wouldn't even label it because
it's not month four right it's not the
fourth pillar this is this each pillar
is its own thing okay and we go through
six in in six months and then you can
join as an alumni and come back at a
discounted price okay it's got to feel
like a new thing every time okay and
then I didn't miss out on anything okay
I know we gotta go but real quick
Belinda what do you got
um I know you don't like Facebook ads
but like for my products especially my
books I mean I don't know how else to
get it out there without doing an ad
what would you suggest
did I say it on like Facebook guides I
don't mind I don't Facebook ads are
great Facebook itself sucks but but
advertisement Facebook and Instagram ads
can be great
um I think the thing with Facebook with
any advertisement is you have to figure
out the messaging first
so you you have to be talking to people
to know what they connect with so as an
example with with TDS right now my salsa
dancing company uh we're launching
virtual classes because people can't
come in and do
you know in-person salsa classes right
now so Alex is off dming people on
Instagram telling them about a free
class that we have and playing with what
what headline like what what's he typing
into the message and then trying to get
them on a call to talk about it
to see what did they resonate with so
when he's giving his pitch or talking
about what we do what questions do they
ask and what resonates with them like
what's the thing that gets people to
then go take the free class from the
conversation that's a giant waste of
time like I I don't need Alex talking
for 30 minutes to get one person to a
free class but what it what it does that
doesn't scale hard but it gives you the
market feedback to know okay when I use
this phrase when I say this sentence
when I position it like this that's what
gets people to open my message and then
go to the free class
that's what then you turn into an
advertisement
okay at the beginning you don't know
what's going to work and so it's it's a
it's a it's a waste of money or or it's
like a learning experience you either
learn by spending a whole bunch of money
on a bunch of different ideas or you
learn by doing the work and talking to
people
so he just DMS random people not people
that's following him just random people
he's dming people so part of the class
is is
is um personal development so it's like
people who join salsa it's not just to
learn the salsa steps they want to make
an improvement in their life right
they're more they don't like where
they're at right now they want to learn
a new skills on their bucket list
something right so he's looking up
hashtag personal development
and then damning people who are in
Canada the US
and that's it but that's like hitting 50
people a day 100 people a day he does a
text message and then a video like hey
Belinda
and then whatever he can what you know
every day is a slightly different
message
right and just to see what people
connect with that then want to set up a
call with him to then talk about the
free class
again it doesn't scale very hard it's a
lot of time but zero money it's just
your time to do it but as he's getting
feedback for what
what people are connecting with
that goes on your landing page so when
you're talking about the book what's the
headline at the top when you're creating
the ad what's the copy what's the
picture when you know what people are
talking about what what they connect
with it's a lot easier for you to make a
better ad
um so for example when we first came up
with the landing page we use text like
um you deserve an adventure
let let us teach you let's let's have a
great adventure tonight with salsa
dancing and
Adventure wasn't connecting when he said
Adventure on the phone nobody resonated
with it so our headline is wrong we need
to take off Adventure like don't talk
about Adventure anymore so as you're
talking to people you say you deserve an
adventure and you see them do nothing
like I didn't I didn't that wasn't a
good okay uh well and then you're kind
of fumbling to come up with whatever
else you can think of and then you say
something like oh that okay great and
then you update the landing page to have
that right so right now it's much more
about
um people feel like they're not
connected they're not connected to
people and that's the messages coming up
so we'll update the page to talk about
connection
and when Alex was talking to more people
it's talking about connection and when
we really dialed that in then it's going
to go to ads Facebook ad Instagram ads
YouTube ads that talk about having
connection right now
because we know that that message works
right
um
if you said hey I've got 10K just to
throw away and test great it's faster
through Facebook ads
but you're going to lose a lot of money
versus just talking to potential
customers and seeing what what resonates
with them
so how to raise your rates when you
realize you are under charging your
clients and customers okay well we can
actually Workshop this what do you sell
Andrew what's what's the business
um so uh it's right up your alley my man
uh so I'm a YouTube consultant I do
optimization and strategy I am
exceptionally busy I don't have a
website I don't promote I don't
advertise don't do anything it's just
Word of Mouth
and I can't keep up I've been turning
work away and just recently realized
that I'm not even charging my existing
clients what would probably be
considered the industry standard
so you're doing
are you uploading are you doing
thumbnails are you just split testing
all videos strategy all of that I
typically insert myself in the client's
organization and I coordinate all the
moving pieces I work with a graphic
designer to do the thumbnails that work
with the video editor I interpret the
data and the metrics uh
geek when it comes to this stuff I
consume everything I've I've learned a
lot about YouTube from yourself and
other and others and in fact I even have
if you haven't picked it up already it's
fantastic YouTube form a fantastic
derral Eves does it mean he just
published this thing a few months ago
right so it's
it's uh the latest and greatest with
regards to YouTube and I've been
deploying what I learned there with with
my clients getting amazing results I
report I do the reporting from my
clients every every week and I have some
very very happy clients but but I'm I'm
realizing that I'm not actually charging
um what would be considered appropriate
and so I'm like ah now I got a problem
so every new client you bring on is 30
more
and then you have a conversation with
existing clients to
increase the rate
makes sense
and you may lose some people
but if it's a good it's a good spot to
be in I mean that there may be one or
two people you keep on just because you
love them and and they just it feels
good to work with them and help them but
they're you know they can't afford the
new rates and so you keep those on other
people uh can easily afford it and and
they have to decide what they're going
to spend it and and other people you
move on from if there's anybody you can
recommend them to great otherwise you're
you're moving on and you start targeting
more ideal clients
um
and I went through this with
um
a couple times now with different
YouTube you know we started with Jeremy
who you know now is mid five figures
sorry mid yeah five figures mid five
figures every month
and his goal is to have 12 ideal clients
who are paying him 5K a month to help
him
yeah I don't know Jeremy but I did
recently connect with Drew and I had a
meeting with him because Zan the man
hooked us up uh introduced us so we
scheduled a meeting yeah and and so that
was eye-opening that was very very
eye-opening to see to see what how Drew
has been how he has structured his
business because it made me realize that
I need to I need to um recalibrate right
yeah well the number one thing I did
when when I helped when I invested into
Drew was start to renegotiate his
current deals
it's like okay wow you're doing way too
much like this is just you're you're
you're not getting you're giving a lot
of value not getting paid so and listen
at the beginning this is helpful for
everybody at the beginning of a coaching
business
you're just figuring stuff out
you're you're happy that any client is
coming to you you're getting paid to do
what you love it's great
um I think a couple things that will
help
uh one
treat every client like it's an annual
deal not just a one-off so even Drew
turned away deals that hey can you help
me for this month like um
you can't get enough Can't Get Enough
value out of it so every now for
depending on the business maybe you can
but by default you want to think about
turning people into annual deals so you
know Terry's going to coach somebody on
how to write a book great let's turn
that into uh what does an annual deal
look like what is a book every year look
like and just default into that kind of
thinking instead of the one-offs
next is breaking down the product offer
so that when you are not just you know
I'll do everything for you for YouTube
great
that's a good starting point but then
you need to start breaking it down so
there's strategy strategy once a month
or every two weeks June and um Jeremy do
every two weeks because for strategy you
don't have enough for uh for every week
and if you're doing it every week you
become
uh more of a project manager which is
maybe what you want to do as opposed to
actually strategy not enough happens
week to week to really justify strategy
um so if you want to be project manager
and I'm going to talk to the designer
and I'm going to get this done and I'm
going to basically as you said insert
yourself into the organization if that's
what you love doing then you have a
project management fee
you have a strategy fee
you have a
split testing fee yes like optimization
fee so so Drew and Jeremy will do
strategy split testing for a certain
number of thumbnails and titles going
back and then guidance on things like
mashup videos uh so everything that you
do is now split
and people can pick packages that they
go for with all of it or they can just
do the one thing and what that helps is
prevent scope creep to then say
oh well Andrew can you also help with
this you know and how about this and and
this too when she's already doing that
can you that happens you're talking my
language Evan thank you yeah that has
most certainly happened that's exactly
where I'm at right now and that happens
to every Consulting business every
coaching business scope creep it's just
the I didn't know that was the term
thank you the scope of the project just
creeps forward right it's like oh and
Terry would you mind also doing this and
how about that it's like that's a whole
other offering that I that I given
listen it's not that you always say no
and you you know you bend a bit but at
some point now if this is every month
that I'm doing this
it has to be part of some kind of
offering that we're putting together
um so some of it can be organic and you
work towards but when you get enough I'm
not so worried about the beginning part
don't worry about having the perfect
plan together but as you get into it you
start to see the pattern so you know for
Jeremy for example he didn't want to do
thumbnails and split testing at the
beginning and and one of his clients
just badly needed it
because she didn't have anybody who
could do it so he said okay you know
what I'm gonna help her and I'm going to
do it and then he realized oh you know
what it's actually not that hard and
I've gained skills to do it
great I'm going to do this for other
clients too awesome try but you have to
charge for it Jeremy that's a new
service now that's an extra 1500 bucks a
month to do split testing on your
catalog that kind of stuff so what I
would look for you is what are the how
do you how would you break it down into
the two to seven things that you're
doing consistently for clients not
nickel and diming them about
every single minute of every phone call
is being like like a lawyer would do you
know that's not what the business you
want to be in but also clients don't
know what goes on behind the scenes they
might just assume it's just easy this
one little thing for you to do right
where it's no no this is actually taking
on a life of its own and now I'm very
deep into your project
um so what are the two to seven things
that you're doing most consistently for
clients and then pricing those out as
different packages that um that you can
help with
that makes sense and in this situation
of if you are working with a client that
you enjoy working with but maybe perhaps
they're on a tighter budget does it make
sense for a YouTube expert to lower the
base fee and just ask to participate in
the YouTube ad Revenue do a red split a
web share
um do you could you could if you see
upside you know if you
sometimes people will do it based off of
a minimum so you know like the first
three thousand dollars a month comes to
you
and you invest in them to help them and
guide them and if you can't help them
you know if they're only making 500
bucks a month then you get the 500 bucks
but you get the first 3 000 or whatever
number you want to put in there that's
worth it for you you get the first so
you're working towards it and then
afterwards what do you
what do you want to work on
um together does that is it your stop
and you just make 3K a month is it then
some kind of share afterwards because it
turns into more of a partnership at that
point right yeah and so you have to pick
those clients extra carefully because
you're investing a ton of time at the
start to do the work and then when they
end up succeeding hopefully like when do
they even do the work to succeed because
only so much you can do as the guy
behind the scenes they have to make
videos you know if they're not making
content and you can't wave a magic wand
then just help you blow up
um I do have one client that I'm
constantly like where are your videos
need your videos yeah it says like do
you still want to work with them you
know is it an ideal client for you or
not
um
and then working towards if I'm going to
take a piece of their Channel forever is
that is it just somebody you love
working with is it a good partner for
you
or not and as you start the build you
get a little more spoiled you can be a
little more picky you know with who you
bring on the kinds of people that you
want to work with
yeah yeah I've I've recently had some
very interesting conversations looks
like I've onboarded my first celebrity
actually so things are things are things
are going quick and I'm trying to be
smart about it and scale in an
appropriate manner so that all my
clients still receive the value that
they're used to receiving from me so
thank you very much Evan I don't want to
take up everyone's time but uh yeah
thank you and just super quick like as
you keep as you keep growing it's for
everybody too hope everybody's valuing
you know the conversation
um the kinds of clients that you want to
work with so for example Jeremy right
now on the YouTube world is only going
after pretty giant names like they're
all everybody on this Client List you
would recognize who they were and what
they're doing
um and that's what he loves doing
um Bo who I've recently invested into he
does he books he books guests for shows
so he he books he got me Matthew
McConaughey and Deepak Chopra and all
these people and then we turned that
into a service for other people so if
you have a podcast or YouTube channel
and you're looking to get some good
guests for it Beau will book the guest
for you
um which is great because that's a big
part of
writing a show is booking guests but
Beau doesn't want to work with the big
name shows Beau likes working with the
people who are on their way up not that
not the totally brand new like
I'm never going to make any money but he
he likes finding people who already have
they have a budget they've had some
success in the entrepreneur world and
they want to launch their show and they
have a budget to launch the show but
they're not people that you know of yet
and he likes
being a part of helping them grow
so it's just a totally different
clientele than what someone like Jeremy
is going after and and at the end of the
day you get the pick you know as you at
the beginning you're exploring and you
don't really know until you start
working with them so working with that
celebrity great amazing and maybe that
that's all you want to do then is work
with more celebrities or you may realize
I actually hate working with these
celebrities I'd rather work with the
level below and help them become and
that's where I get my biggest
satisfaction there's no right answer
it's more what does Andrew want to do
um and for everybody else as you start
getting into the coaching business you
get the pick because of all the things
that's the most like working with a bad
client a non-ideal fit client starts to
suck the soul out of you because it's
your actual time that you're spending
every week with them
um so those learnings of the people who
you want to start working with become
important as you build your coaching
practice thank you what do we got
uh thanks Evan for your time again
or taking our questions today and um I
just wanted some feedback I just started
my YouTube channel last month so it's
brand new
um just wanted your opinion on am I
doing well or am I not
um it's called Soul aligned vision
how often are you posting uh once a week
okay so let's work to up that
okay twice a week or as much as you can
because because part of it is just
developing the skill set of getting
getting better
okay where if you're if you're
practicing anything once a week anything
the odds of you getting really good at
it are pretty low okay so as as much as
you can
um I'd be making more videos uh I'd be
going longer like most years I'm looking
at like five six minutes yeah
10 minutes plus
okay we just talked about this inside
Movie Makers today like I'd be leaving
looking towards hour long videos if you
have enough con like you can actually
speak to it but at least 10 minutes on
it okay
um and then just just more just more
more videos more videos
like I would I wouldn't judge yourself
until you have 100 videos on the channel
okay
and you've got seven which is great hey
seven first seven are the hardest to do
that's amazing but you know seven videos
listen seven videos in four weeks that's
a that's a good start
um but if you really want to start
picking up traction
I'd be I'd have Ambitions to go to one
video a day that are you know 10 minutes
plus each one
okay and and don't don't worry as much
about the editing I don't know if you
are worried about the editing or what
you're doing but
um I'm not because it was keeping me
from posting anything at all so perfect
just post next and then post again next
and then post again next
um and start to look at your data and
detraction like commit commit mentally
to making 100 videos okay or you say
it's not working or you can't make it or
it's not happening for you or whatever
100 videos in your head you'll get way
better or like you're probably already
better now compared to the first video I
am yeah and that's only seven videos in
okay but now imagine 70 videos in you're
gonna just be so much better and you'll
get your Rhythm and your flow down so uh
yeah before worrying about there's not
enough data or analytics to really pour
into yet when it's too soon
on a channel
uh because you know some of them have
done okay right like 84 views 170 views
on your mother's day one it's great
um
but yeah daily commit to 100 videos
you've done seven so you got 93 more
10 minute Plus videos
and that's the start okay yeah so it
should it's okay to post seven videos
and not Market them first
um
or is it better to do three and then
Market them
so have time to Market them every other
day
Market them through what like a
newsletter send yeah send them send
people the videos you post post I post
every day and then take your best video
from the past week and then put that in
your newsletter okay
so not every video will get we'll hit
your newsletter which is fine
I do 20 to 30 videos a day
wow and not every video hits a
newsletter
okay yeah okay thanks cool good luck
lady what do you got well I'm recently
yeah
um uh created a bunch of videos or I
recorded a bunch of videos which were
all consecutive
and I was thinking about what you said
before because normally you you start
with something like an intro and get
people to get in so somewhere in between
I made a seven minute long video which
actually got into it all but I'm still
thinking can I still use the other
tidbit because I was going for a walk
and every time I saw something I just
recorded and talked about it
so it's part of a series but you want to
also talk about other things
yeah I was I was just going for a walk
it was an hour long walk so every few
minutes I I would record a few minutes
of things I thought about and and things
I saw and then when I actually was
sitting down that's when I made one
according to the structure you always
say so later on I edited them all
together into one YouTube video and I
was thinking this isn't working so I I
never actually posted the video
well how do you know it's not working if
you haven't posted a video
um that's true
then also just post it and maybe change
the format a little bit yeah I mean and
that's the part of if you're committing
to 100 videos
great you post it it doesn't work
awesome next
okay because you got 100 to make that's
just one you got 99 more to go
you know I will play with you
walking more and maybe you discover that
when you walk like half the audio it
sucks because the wind hit the
microphone
post next and like get a better mic next
time or don't go out on a windy day or
whatever right just post and keep going
next and in in the Rhythm you'll find
what you love
and then what actually is also
resonating with the audience and then
that's what you commit to continuing to
do but in the early stages
don't say something's not working if you
haven't posted it just because
you know the vibe was off or you know
whatever reason did post
you take your hour video and you cut it
up or you just take the hour video and
you just
post it as is and then tomorrow and the
other one comes up and you'll find that
in those hundred videos you'll get a few
winners
awesome thank you if you want to get a
copy of build to serve and join us live
for our next training with me to ask
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love